one of the more prominent displays at
the Air and Space Museum is the spirit
of st. Louis this is a videotape of the
plane it's above the main entrance the
museum on the mall it's not far from our
studios folks visit the Air and Space
Museum this is one of the first things
they see the spirit of st. Louis and
tomorrow is the 74th anniversary of the
day that Charles Lindbergh took off on
his solo flight in that plane across the
Atlantic and landed near Paris and this
book Charles Lindbergh an American life
was edited by our guest Tom crouch he's
senior curator for Aeronautics at the
National Air and Space Museum thanks
very much for being with us thank you
Lee
what impact did Lindbergh's flight have
on America in 1927 and what impact does
it still have today in 1927 it had an
incredible impact I think when you look
back over the history of the 20th
century it's tough to find many
Americans who have been as famous as as
celebrated as Charles Lindbergh was as
you went through the course of the
century in the course of his life you
know he was obviously less famous at the
end than he was in 1927 but he was
always a presence all was a spokesman
for his point of view on a variety of
important subjects from aviation in the
20s and 30s to the environment after
World War two if he hadn't made this
flight somebody would have at some point
what significance is it that it was him
and not somebody else I think the fact
that it was him was incredibly
significant because he looked as though
he was cut out for this role you know he
was young he was 25 years old yet that
tousled hair incredibly good-looking kid
and you know he just looked like the boy
next door though the guy you'd want your
daughter to to bring home to meet the
folks it was just the perfect
representative of of this nation and for
him to do this thing just put that extra
stamp on it
you're right someone else would have
done it probably very soon after he did
it if he hadn't done it but the fact
that it was him made a big difference
Tom crouch is senior curator for Aaron
the National Air and Space Museum is the
editor of this book Charles Lindbergh
and American Life and tomorrow marks the
74th anniversary of that flight across
the Atlantic Lee's first solo flight the
spirit of st. Louis of course on display
at the Air and Space Museum down on the
mall here in Washington DC we invite
your calls over the next 40 minutes or
so for Tom Crouch we talked about the
life of Charles Lindbergh how this
flight affected America then and now and
what his contribution has been to
American life even as we continue into
the 21st century again this footage of
what you see when you go to the second
story of the Air and Space Museum you
get a chance to see the spirit of st.
Louis up close Tom Crouch when people
see that airplane like it is on display
right there what do they think about it
well there's no doubt that it's in the
Smithsonian Institution is a place with
you know a bajillion icons things that
Americans connect with from the Star
Spangled Banner to Lincoln's top hat to
Washington's uniform coat but there
can't be any doubt that the spirit of
st. Louis is one of those objects in the
Smithsonian that people even now 74
years after the flight connect with it
just still has that power I think
explain what was happening in 1927 in
society but also in his life that that I
mean actually led to this event after
all all of us know I think that the
1920s was the great age of celebrity it
was the first stage of the movie star I
mean people like Mary Pickford and
Charlie Chaplin and and Douglas
Fairbanks it was the age of the sports
hero a Red Grange Babe Ruth here comes
this again young kid who isn't doing
something on a ball diamond or on the
silver screen this is real life he can
get Higgins as his life doing what he's
doing this is something that not
everybody can do it's clearly a very
extraordinary sort of thing so he just
you know coming at that moment when
Americans were sort of captivated by the
notion of celebrity and heroism he just
sort of was the capstone of that era
just sort of the perfect example of
young American manhood Todd Crouch with
us until the top of the hour a little
less than
40 minutes the book he edited is Charles
Lindbergh an American life and one of
the more recent books number of books
about Charles Lindbergh but a more
recent book as this Pulitzer
prize-winning book this is the cover-up
but this is by a Scott Berg called
Lindbergh I'll be talking about Charles
Lindbergh for the rest of our program
this morning Albuquerque New Mexico
good morning yes good morning thank you
sue spans I'd like to take exception to
the characterization of mr. Lindbergh as
the boy next door mr. Lindbergh was a
Nazi lover and someone that associated
with the Field Marshall Goering and was
awarded a medal by the Nazis and you
know I take exception very very much so
since my family's fought the Nazis and
he was a collaborator with the enemy
right when I said boy next door I was
talking about public perceptions of him
in 1927 in fact even in 1927 he wasn't
really the boy next door he'd been the
son of an American congressman grew up
under you know fairly wealthy
circumstances more so than than usual so
it's just the people perceived him as
the boy next door
and you're right one of the interesting
things about Charles Lindbergh as an
American as a figure whose life and
career sort of stretches across the
middle of the century is the fact that
he went from this real occasion of
celebrity in 1927 and the years after to
just the nadir in 1939 1940 when he was
connected with with the Nazis when he
did make racist and and anti-semitic
comments and and that sort of thing and
so you have this character who who
really does reach the heights and the
depths in terms of the way in which
people look at him understand them the
spirit of st. Louis of course the most
obvious display of the Air and Space
Museum of the life and times of Charles
Lindbergh there
numerous other items at the Air and
Space Museum regarding his life and we
had an opportunity to see some of those
which actually haven't been on public
display and Tom Crouch is gonna help us
as we look through some of those and
part of the footage we have is of
something called the spinner which I
understand is the nosecone from the
plane tell us about the the spinner and
who these names are why they're there
the spinner is the thing in front of the
propeller on the very nose of the
airplane sort of makes smooth and
aerodynamic shape in the front
Lindbergh of course flew the spirit of
st. Louis from San Diego where it was
built in that spring of 1927 all the way
across the country stopped in st. Louis
to curtis fields in new york and when he
was on the ground in new york the
mechanics at curtis field noticed that
there was a crack in the spinner in the
little plate that comes behind it and so
they took this original spinner off the
airplane and manufactured a new one and
put it on this is the spinner now in our
collection of the museum that was
originally on the airplane and all the
names that you see in there are the
names of the Ryan factory workers who
built the spirit of st. Louis and at
least the first glance it appears
there's a swastika in the middle yeah
yeah really sort of stunning in view of
Lindbergh's later connections and the
way in which people understood him and
so on
of course prior to the rise of the Nazis
in Germany the swastika had been a
symbol of many things good luck I guess
in Native American cultures and in
someone luncher that's what that
represents so that's been are actually
manufactured in mid late 1920s it was
manufactured in 1927
we have other footage we'll be seeing
later in our program of some of the
exhibits that are down at the
Smithsonian regarding the spirit of st.
Louis and the life and times of Charles
Lindbergh our next calls from San Diego
good morning good morning gentlemen how
are you two doing this morning yes yeah
that's good my question is not so much
about Charles Lindbergh as for mr.
crouch if he has I see that he's the
curator of
of a museum or so forth and I was
wondering if you had any
african-american aviator there inside
the museum and now I'll be quiet and
listen
thank you yes we sure do we have an
exhibit on african-americans in the
history of aviation their role both in
the development of American aviation and
all of all of that sort of thing and
we've talked about an expanded
exhibition on that subject too
we published a book at the National Air
and Space Museum on African Americans
and aviation and helped the Smithsonian
Institution traveling exhibition service
produce a traveling exhibition that
folks may have seen on the road and also
during our next half hour we're gonna be
talking on the telephone for a few
minutes with Trez Lindbergh's daughter
Reva Lindbergh who is an author and
she's written a book about one of the
pioneers an African American aviation
she'll be on the phone with us a little
bit later Arlington Texas good morning
yes the the flight that he did across
the Atlantic in so that during the
flight that he had a fly flying around
inside the is is this real or is this
just make-believe for television the the
thing that you're talking about with the
fly flying around in the cockpit and
he's wondering you know if a fly is
flying inside the airplane does that add
to the the total weight that the
airplanes carrying and that sort of
thing is from the from the film I don't
think it's actually in the book spirit
of st. Louis that that Lindbergh wrote
about the flight I could be wrong but I
think it's just in the film was he still
living when the film was made with Jimmy
Stewart he was you know it's not about
it and played some role in it not much I
don't think he went he actually flew
with a pilot named Frank Tallman who was
doing the flying for the movie he
actually flew in their replica
spirit of st. Louis and and that kind of
thing so one of the photographs that's
included in the book that Tom Crouch
edited on Charles Lindbergh in America
life is this early on the morning of May
20th the spirit was towed from Curtiss
to Roosevelt field where the gas tanks
were topped off in preparation for the
take off again 74 years ago tomorrow
Walnut Ridge Arkansas good morning
there's Arkansas good morning good
morning
I wanted to correct the statement that
was just made Lindbergh was not a Nazi
lover he loved his country America and
he saw he didn't want us to get involved
in a war in Europe and he was proved
right what that war did was turned half
of Europe over to the Communists and
they lived under deplorable conditions
they persecuted Christians Lindbergh was
right we should have stayed out of that
war
we had no business in Europe thanks very
much Tom crouch I I don't think he was a
Nazi lover at all I think it was the
sort of comments that he had made during
the the America first movement when a
great many Americans argued that that
this country should remain isolated from
World War two that folks regarded as
anti-semitic or or even racist and he
had visited Germany and and accepted a
medal from the Germans which sort of
surprised him but he had accepted it and
that worked worked against him as well
so in 1939 1940 he was just an
incredibly controversial figure most
recent book about Charles Lindbergh is
this by a Scott Berg Pulitzer Prize
winning book this is the cover of the
book and on the inside numerous
photographs as this photograph from 1968
of Charles Lindbergh giving away in
marriage his youngest child Reeve and
Reeve Lindbergh is on the phone with us
now good morning thanks for joining us
tell us a little bit if you would the
most vivid memories you have of your
parents I remember my parents as
extremely vivid and grew up with them I
knew them for him for 30 years and she
for 50 she 55 actually she died in
spring
earlier this spring and I thought they
represented America in the 20th century
very very much both of them was a
triumph and the tragedies and the
controversies and I think that
everything that people look to them for
or think about them really represents
America right down to the pre-war period
all of that so it was I'm glad to hear
the comments I think it's a that's a
very crucial part of their history and
very interesting but it's really about
America what do you think their lives
then and legacy are to us as you
mentioned the 20th century as we enter
the 21st mmm-hmm I think it's a legacy I
always say it's a legacy of words and
wings and I also think it is a way for
us to get to go into the future I use
this legacy I'm a children's author I
was just down at the Air and Space
Museum for a program about Bessie
Coleman first licensed african-american
aviator in the world and I was inspired
by my parents to take a look at the
other people who weren't so famous and
if they are absolutely wonderful
actually one of our early callers asked
about writing about the early pioneers
of african-american aviation you've
written about Bessie Coleman tell us
about her contributions well Becky
Coleman was born at a time when women
couldn't vote and if you were
african-american you basically couldn't
do anything and she what she did she was
born in 1892 she died in 1926 a year
before my father flew the ocean and she
basically just said hey I'm gonna do
this and she did and for children it's a
wonderful wonderful lesson so when I
talk to children I show a picture of my
father and say this was the hero of the
century and here's another and then I
show a picture of Bessie because there
are many unsung heroes who didn't get
famous and my parents really got too
famous they lost a child their life was
quite distorted by the same despite the
wonderful contributions and it seems to
me that's part of a legacy of Fame as
you begin to shed light on what other
people have done and kind of even things
up a bit so the children can be inspired
by all the heroes whether they're things
or not we're looking at books of course
written by others but you a family
member have written the book a memoir
about your life in the the Lindbergh
family and from that
what do you want people to know about
your parents that that that only you're
able to tell the story that outside
authors can't well I think I need to
know that they were very human they were
individuals with with great strengths
certainly false tragedies and triumphs
and all that but nobody's famous at home
and that's really what I know about I
know that that from the inside Charles
and Anne Lindbergh were also parents
they were also a husband and wife they
were people with many friendships and
and they were individuals like all of us
so I wrote about that I mean I didn't
know he was famous and I flew with him
every practice every Saturday one year
and I was a little bored and there's a
story about my son and the spirit of st.
Louis in the Smithsonian which I love
which is that he and I went up in the
cherry picker to look at the spirit and
I could touch it for the first time when
he was 10 1997 and I put my hand out and
touched the airplane and I turned to ban
with tears in my eyes and I said he was
amazing and he said yeah I said I've
never been in a cherry picker before we
of course have asked you for a few
minutes of your time and thank you for
joining us but a task but your views on
this but tell us a little bit more about
Ben and how he sees his grandfather well
he was just there he was just there and
I want to thank all the Air and Space
guys and ladies and everybody all the
people there for helping with this 8th
grade class trip he's interested but I
think for him I mean he's the person of
the 21st century and he he takes very
much for granted all that happened
before so and I think that's terrific I
think the kids just should go forward
and think about the next century and
what they're gonna do and and not get
too overwhelmed by what went before but
be proud of it I think we need to be
proud of it and I think we need to be
conscious that this is a wonderful
history as many implications for better
and for worse and then we go on reeve
Lindbergh also an author what else are
you working on these days I'm working on
a wonderful book called the awful
aardvark
all over America and that's for very
young children and I write about I have
write rhyming books about these crazy
animals and they are
if anybody has suggestions just you know
let me know I need the aardvark to do
wonderful American thing
brave Lindbergh the daughter of Charles
Lindbergh thank you very much for a few
minutes for us this morning
thank you joining us on the phone from
Vermont this morning again this is the
book by a Scott burg Lindbergh future
prize-winning book and our guest edited
this book this book Charles Lindbergh an
American life and our guest Tom Crouch
of the National Air and Space Museum is
senior curator for Aeronautics with us
till the top of the hour about another
25 minutes some observations about what
reeve Lindbergh had to say yeah there's
another Lindbergh grandchild
Eric Lindbergh who's been sort of the
family representative on the group that
put together the XPrize the XPrize is
supposed to encourage private trips into
space you know you you the development
has to be private and you have to send a
certain three-minute people I think up
and you have to do it again within a
month to to be sure you can really do it
safely and get them back and there's a
prize established and of course he
argues you know that this XPrize
business is something like the Orteig
prize that his grandfather won when he
flew the Atlantic in 1927 and when he
when he won that prize there was money
how much $25,000 yeah Raymond Orteig was
a hotel yegg who was born in Paris and
ran hotels in New York so he thought he
would establish this prize to link his
two cities and they he did it in 1919
with a five-year time limit and of
course nobody did it in those five years
so he renewed it and that Charles
Lindbergh was the man to win the prize
and we have in one of our graphics a
picture of the check Charles Lindbergh
won the $25,000 prize that's it it
resides in the safe and the Aeronautics
Department these days
well I mentioned earlier about some of
the footage that we have of some of the
things you have down there that haven't
been on public display how many things
do you have related to Charles Lindbergh
Oh quite a few most of them are usually
on display with a Lockheed serious that
Charles and Anna Lindbergh flew on a
number of great flights in the night
30s but that part of the museum is sort
of walled off they're working on it now
so we have a lot of that material up
under lock and key and that's where your
crew came to shoot it the other day
thanks for letting us in Reve Lindberg
mentioned the fact that the Lindbergh's
had lost a child this is the wanted
poster that was issued back in 1932 for
information on the whereabouts of
Charles a Lindbergh jr. Hopewell New
Jersey as you can see son of Colonel
Charles Lindbergh world famous aviator
tell us about what's known now as the
kidnapping of the Lindbergh baby
the Lindbergh's were never able to
escape the public view at least not
before World War two whatever they were
doing it was on the front pages of the
newspapers and the kidnapping in some
sense I think they always saw as a
result of their sort of unwanted
celebrity and part of what it what it
brought with them but again it was one
of those moments in the Lindbergh story
that are just incredible because of the
level of press interest and that just
the incredible ballyhoo and brouhaha and
so on that was going on around the
originally the kidnapping and then the
long extended search for the kidnappers
and then the capture and trial of Bruno
Richard Hauptmann and his execution
ultimately the whole thing led the
Lindbergh's to move to Europe actually
to sort of escape the kind of pressure
that they were getting from the from the
press constantly Tom Crouch senior
curator for Aeronautics at the National
Air and Space Museum with us until the
top of the hour when baver jigna good
morning good morning up but I have a
good friend who's an engineer who
commented on Lindbergh's aircraft engine
as we recall the fact that the trip took
about thirty three hours and in the
aircraft engines of the 1920s basically
would not run that long according to my
friend without a major overhaul so they
basically wouldn't run long enough to
make it across the ocean the right
people had an engine
that they basically would guarantee
would run for 40 hours and Lindbergh
figured that was of course long enough
for the trip so not to detract from
anything else Lindbergh accomplished my
friend indicates that the engine he used
was a critical factor in making the trip
thank you thank you yeah there's no
doubt about that the engine of course
was a right whirlwind and it was the the
great engine of the era Lindbergh wasn't
the the first guy to fly with one on his
airplane Richard Byrd in fact had flown
to the North Pole and back the year
before with with right whirl winds but
in terms of Lindbergh's flight across
the Atlantic in May of 1927 there just
can't be any doubt that the the engine
was the cornerstone of that airplane of
his success talked earlier about the the
kidnapping in the Scott burg book
Lindbergh one of the photographs from
UPI in the Corvis Bederman files as
Lindbergh on the stand and the cut line
of this is once he testified his
attorney said afterward the trial was
over that's him on the stand on the left
upper left of this photograph Alexandria
Virginia good morning
now examview good morning other hi I
just wanted to ask Charles Lindbergh if
I want I actually what I wanted to know
was about Russian people during this
time I mean when he when he made his
flight exactly he when they were in
Europe he made a number of long-distance
flights
one of which was to Russia it was a
country that he wasn't terribly
comfortable with but he went there in
fact I think he flew a miles Mohawk that
he was operating at the time he
mentioned earlier the criticism he
received in the late 1930s leading up to
the war but the war started he did want
to fly but what happened going all the
way back to 1934 when he was involved in
a dis
buuuut over-the-air mail and the
airlines for which he was working with
President Roosevelt he and Roosevelt
began to develop very better feelings
and of course in 1940 with the America
first movement Roosevelt had just turned
against him completely and Lindbergh's
patriotism and that sort of thing were
questioned and Lindbergh had resigned
his Commission in the Air Corps Reserve
and once the war began of course he
didn't want to serve he wanted to get
back in and Roosevelt simply wouldn't
have it
Lindbergh spent the early part of the
war as a consultant to a number of
aircraft companies engine companies and
that kind of thing
got into the South Pacific ultimately
and he simply showed up in the South
Pacific and worked himself into a
situation where he began to fly combat
missions he had originally gone out to
try to help younger pilots understand
fuel control and that sort of thing to
increase the range that they could get
out of their airplanes and again he
stayed and flew the normal tour of
combat missions shot at least one
Japanese airplane down most of the
missions that they were involved in in
those days were strafing ships and
islands and and there so on and so forth
but it was really extraordinary this guy
who was in his forties twice the age of
many of the younger pilots that that he
was dealing with and able to not only
keep up with them but sort of outfly
them and they loved it they had a great
time flying with this most famous
aviator of the century there was a early
on when he when he began flying with
them there was a moment that one of them
loved to tell about it was apparently a
little slow getting his wheels up after
takeoff and so after they'd taken off
and he was a little slow this time the
flight commander radio to um you know
Lindbergh get your wheels up you think
you're flying the spirit of st. Louis we
have some other footage from air in
space what we're going to look and just
a men
at some of the maps he use but we'll
take a phone call first and then have
Tom Crouch tell us about the maps but
before that Oklahoma City good morning
hello mr. Crouch good morning
there were two observations that that
struck me the initial one was the
spinner yes and just to corroborate what
you would indicated that was a
counterclockwise facing swastika which
was the Indian good luck symbol long
before the Nazis had come on the scene
right with their mirror image thereof
right and the more important feature
which you just touched on while I was
waiting
specifically the the animosity that
Roosevelt had toward Lindbergh just a
one further observation on that point if
you start reading Roosevelt's
conversations and correspondences it
becomes quickly apparent that he had
already decided 1939 or even before that
the United States would go to war
against Nazi Germany that was his agenda
as demonstrated by a book that you may
already know of called day of deceit
that has to do with the Pearl with the
Pearl Harbor raid and Washington's
foreknowledge of it thanks to the
code-breaking
which has which had been kept secret for
many years we had gone much further in
that regard and since you are on the air
at historian if you're not familiar with
that when I would commend that one did
to your to your attention since it
centers on Pearl Harbor thanks for the
call well again Roosevelt and Lindbergh
had a long and unhappy history with one
another interesting these two men who
arguably were the most famous individual
Americans of their other time from one
of the photographs of the book that Tom
Crouch edited on Charles Lindbergh in
American life is this in his early days
in a two-seater biplane you mentioned
our crew being able to shoot some of the
objects that you have that aren't
generally on public display including
some of the maps and the South American
trip that he took that we'll be seeing
right now what's the significance of
these maps
this is a map that he carried with him
in the spirit of st. Louis when he made
a trip through Latin America in from
very late 1927 into early 1928
interestingly enough it was on this trip
that he met Anne Morrow who whom he was
to marry of course her father Dwight
Morrow was the American ambassador to
Mexico at the time and they met when
when Lindbergh was in Mexico City but
specifically the interesting thing about
this map is that it shows the area
around Cuba and late in his flight when
he was coming back to the United States
this was a map that he had when when he
was getting ready to land in Havana and
you see the the writing handwriting on
the map
when you read this what you realize is
that he's the spirit of st. Louis has
arrived over the airport a little before
he's supposed to land and since there's
gonna be a big ceremony and he has
plenty of fuel he wants to circle so he
can land at the correct time and he's
written the remarks that he's going to
make when when he lands and gets out of
the airplane on the on the map we have
this map on exhibit gosh for about 20
years in a case downstairs and didn't
really recognize that his handwritten
remarks the speech notes were on there
and we had to take it out that colleague
took it out a couple of years ago and we
were stunned and delighted this really
human touch that we discovered one of
the books we have on her desk this
morning again the story
Lindbergh by a Scott Burton Pulitzer
prize-winning book and in it our
photographs mentioned several times it
could tell us a little bit more about
Anne Morrow Lindbergh two of the
photographs one is is Anne Lindbergh
photographed in Nanking it says became
Charles's copilot navigator and radio
operator that a close-up of her it's not
dated and then next to that is a picture
of them together
the book says they became the first
couple of the skies yeah the the
photograph that showed her in the white
helmet was taken in 1931 when they made
a trip that became her book north
the Orient flying north through the
Canadian north and down Alaska across
the Siberian coast and down to Japan and
China studying great circle routes for
Airlines to come and so on two years
later they flew around the Atlantic
Basin across the North Atlantic down the
European and African coast and back up
the South Atlantic coast again scouting
air routes and and making those sorts of
studies for the airlines that were to
come Lindbergh
during these years was always closely
connected to Civil Aeronautics TWA what
became TWA was the Lindbergh line that
was one of their selling points he was a
key advisor to TWA and to Pan Am as well
Juan Terry trips chosen instrument sort
of American aerial policy abroad and
Lindbergh was was one of the leaders of
Pan Am and and sort of for Pan Am that
he undertook the the Atlantic trip and
Anne Morrow Lindbergh wrote a book about
that trip to listen the wind you
mentioned several times about this the
late 20s early 30s being that the first
time we saw the media stars even
superstars there are times if you could
again
tell us what impact them being these the
new media stars had on America it had it
and they they their image had an
enormous impact on America they were
always in the newspapers and every time
you saw them they were like the pictures
that you just showed they were in flying
togs and and tell mitts and goggles and
and that sort of thing and Morrow
Lindbergh became a symbol of the air age
really quite as much as her husband did
and that that was that was important she
was an extraordinary woman who went
through the same sort of cycles of
popularity and unpopularity as as her
husband did these photographs we've been
looking at the last few moments from the
book Lindbergh by a Scott Berg
Hill North Carolina good morning good
morning I want to thank you for c-span
first just think that the Lindbergh's
history their biographies will always be
interesting and enthralling to Americans
because they show first if the
Lindbergh's are humans and that like any
human they are subject to heartbreaking
personal tragedy and that they their
lives doing compass many ambiguities and
contradictions so I think they'll always
be fascinating but the real thing I
wanted to talk about was the swastika
emblem the emam that was shown on the
part that came from Lindbergh plane is a
replica of the emblem used by the early
Indian
the early American Indians and was a
sort of symbol of good luck
I am amused by the Nazi Party if you
will examine them is very it's similar
but different the American emblem shows
the the arms that bend bend
counterclockwise they're aiming they're
going counterclockwise if you look at
the Nazi emblem they go counterclockwise
so you you should really before you say
that it's a Nazi emblem you should
examine the swastika to see which way
the arms Bend if they go to the right
doing there the Nazi of them if they go
to the left there the old did the Indian
emblem thanks thanks very much thank you
our guest Tom Crouch is senior curator
for Aeronautics of the National Air and
Space Museum and has the as a biography
that's small print a full page here I
don't think I could begin to read all
this but the author on a number of books
has a BA in history from Ohio University
an MA in history from Miami University
and a PhD in American history from Ohio
State is hometown is Dayton Ohio a
number of positions with the National
Air and Space Museum is a currently
senior curator for aeronautics and is
working on a new book tentatively titled
it says here wings a centennial history
of the airplane publisher will be Norton
what are you working on wings as as you
said it's sort of a one-volume narrative
history of the airplane and probably
best known as a biographer of the Wright
brothers I like doing biography so this
one has been a little different you have
to stand way
back and sort of look at the big picture
the big twists and turns and what's
really made a difference and certainly
Charles Lindbergh is a is a character in
that book aside from his impact on
American life that we've talked about
quite a bit what did this flight mean to
the aviation business oh it had an
enormous impact on the aviation business
because of federal legislation passed in
the mid 1920s there was already a little
sort of boomlet underway in terms of
aviation stocks investing in aviation
and that sort of thing and again
Lindbergh's like just sort of put the
cap on that it turned into a full-scale
boom that ultimately exploded in fact of
course during the Depression but he just
became sort of the living symbol of
everything that interested people about
aviation know the extent to which it
underscored values that that Americans
had always cherished courage and
determination and the ability to soar
over obstacles and that kind of thing he
really embodied all of that he came from
this technical background and in later
years became involved in technology was
also interested in the environment tell
us a little bit about his later life one
of the really interesting things about
Lindbergh is the extent to which you can
see him undergoing sea changes to some
sort to some degree early in his career
as he himself said he was really a great
believer in the power of Science and
Technology to change the world for the
better late later in his life after
World War two he became much more
concerned about other sorts of issues
about environmental issues about
cultures he was interested in in the
tacit a people of the Philippines he
actually had friends in in East Africa
he was worried about the extent to which
globalism was destroying traditional
cultures and and the wildlife
conservation
all of those sorts of issues he in fact
was an opponent of the American
supersonic transport when that issue was
being argued in the Congress and at
other venues as well and that he really
argued against it because of
environmental concerns over damage to
the the upper atmosphere noise those
sorts of those sorts of issues this is
one of the photographs from the book by
a Scott Berg Lindbergh a picture of
Charles Lindbergh in 1967 in Indonesia
Bowling Green Ohio good morning good
morning I wanted to mention what I think
was a moral in Berg's
most important book it's in my hand and
it's only 41 pages and the title is the
wave of the future all right
always sits on the coffee table here and
the other day I happen to have young
children 16 and 14 very revolutionary
minded and they picked it up and they
thought it was current literature I hope
one of the Lindbergh's is on the still
watching the show and can hear that this
what's it about it's a 41 page book it
was often described at the time as a
defense of Charles Lindbergh's
isolationist views and it's really
partly that but it's much more a
forward-looking essay on saying it the
way to a better world is through
remaining peaceful not engaging in a
European war and there's things to be
criticized here but mostly it's a very
heartfelt book from mrs. Lindbergh and I
hope it stays always in print it can
still be found and used bookstores Tom
crouch yeah of course mrs. Lindbergh was
heavily criticized for the wave of the
future as her husband was for speeches
that he had made the Des Moines speech
or articles that he had written for The
Reader's Digest and other publications
because in the wave of the
as people read it they seemed perhaps to
understand that she thought democracy
far from being the wave of the future
was losing ground was a dying approach
and in fact she seems to have been
suggesting that the wave of the future
is something very different indeed
something represented by totalitarian
regimes another photograph in the a
Scott burg book called Lindbergh is this
President Johnson and vice president
Humphrey looking on as Charles Lindbergh
and the right side of the photograph
signing autographs in 1968 for the
Apollo astronauts at the White House San
Diego good morning oh where the spirit
of st. Louis was built indeed as I
understand it the Atlantic's had been
crossed many times by the air and that
Lindbergh whistle first person do it's
all right so why was it so such a big
deal well you're right
the Atlantic had been flown many times
beginning in 1919 when the US Navy's nc4
made the flight across for the first
time and the couple of Britons John
Alcock and Arthur wit and brown fluid in
a Vickers Vimy non-stop and by the time
Lindbergh had flown it a great many
people had had already done it and so
you're right the question is why was
that solo flight so important and I
think the key to that is a mixture of
understanding that a lot of people had
tried to do it before Lindbergh in
earlier in 1927 and it had been a big
news story six people that actually died
trying to do it in the the six months or
so before Lindbergh did it so it was the
the Atlantic was in the headlines again
and again the other part of it was him
the way he looked the way he presented
himself as we said he was just sort of
the the perfect image of young American
manhood that it captivated everyone I've
always thought it was interesting that
the
aviator who did that the following year
1928 was Amelia Earhart who flew the
Atlantic with a pilot and another fellow
in 1928 and she was often described as
you know the lady Lindbergh with the
tousled hair and slim and and that sort
of thing so I think if you want to
understand why it was such a big deal
he's very much a part of that in these
Saturday segments looking at at the
history of people who have influenced
America we've been looking at a number
of photographs from this book it's the
prize-winning book by a Scott Berg
Lindbergh our guest this morning is the
editor of this Charles a Lindbergh and
American Life Tom Crouch is also senior
curator for Aeronautics the National Air
and Space Museum and his new book to be
published by Norton tentatively titled
wings a centennial history of the
airplane thank you very much thank you